[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: We're going to
deploy a virtual machine using
Cloud Deployment Manager
using Cloud Shell.
Click the pencil at the top
to open the text editor.
In the File menu, choose New
File and name it vm.yaml.
Paste the config file from the
Quick Start into this file.
First, define the
virtual machine instance
using this config file.
This establishes the machine
type, image family, zone, disk,
and IP.
Replace the
placeholder variables
in the new yaml file with your
preferred project and VM image
family.
There are two instances
of my project,
and one instance of family name.
Deploy these resources
using gcloud referencing
the yaml just created.
Your deployment has succeeded.
We now have a new
instance deployed.
It's quick to check
on your deployment
with the described
command in gcloud, which
shows us the information about
a deployment plus any warnings
or errors.
Moving to the Cloud
Console Web UI,
we can see that our deployment
is shown in the Deployment
Manager section.
Clicking in gives
us more information
about the resources
included, and we
can get details on the
VM from here as well.
You've now completed
your first deployment.
Congratulations.
[MUSIC PLAYING]